Joseph you are gonna be my business you
know I was obsessed with him as well at
the time I was a fanboy the apprentice
Joseph about how you how you got on and
stuff so what what was the application
process life did you think you're gonna
get accepted on to the show like talked
about and what made you what what really
made you do it
okay so first question what you said did
you think I was gonna get on a lot of
people say to me did I think I was gonna
win it and my answer is all of course
like what I was gonna win it nobody
enters into a competition if they don't
think they can win or they might do and
that's why they don't win right so first
and foremost yes i 100% knew that i was
going to win and you have to think try
that if you want to succeed right you
know a lot of people say about the
application process what did you say how
did you act you know I said I wanted to
be the godfather of business make Lord
Sugar an offer you cannot refuse my one
of my people that I admired was do
Hefner I wanted to be a playboy I wanted
to go funny all of these things what you
got to say those things right because
number one at the time I kind of
believed it I was 25 years old and
single and I was doing quite well and I
liked that lifestyle and I wanted to be
rich and famous and have cars and houses
pretty girlfriends that was just how I
pour that time Joseph do you think that
they like that kind of thing because if
they have people with a big ego it's
more entertaining for the viewer to
watch them people then get crushed
without a doubt yeah you're not gonna go
on there saying listen I I let my
actions do the talking you'd never get
accepted yeah you're not gonna write any
application
I let my actions speak for me but then
they say oh you not quite you know
you've gotta work you've got to
understand what game you're playing in
life everything is a game right are you
going to understand what the rules of
the game are if you want to apply to get
on a competition like that what are the
rules it again why would they need to
see who I am and I need to make these
statements I need to make them believe
I'm gonna be entertaining I need to give
them proven track records of what I've
done something I'm gonna be successful I
need to create myself with their ideal
profile so they choose me there's 60,000
people applying for this stuff so how do
you get in there if you're not unique
write to always understand the game that
you're in and then it's the same one
you've got on the show you know there
were certain things you know that you
would that you'd there's no there's no
fake recording but you know you
understand what type of what type of
attitude you need for the producers you
understand what the kind of things they
want you to say you think I understand
how you need to act you know and they
have their way of editing and filming so
if you can master what they need and do
it for them your double play in the game
um and that's the skill that people need
to be able to master you know and and
and that helps and that helped me you
know and I was able to do it but I was
very very true to myself I was very
straight I was very open very honest one
of the things you didn't do in the
apprentice you didn't like badmouth
everybody you didn't come across
arrogant at all I didn't think on the
actual show yeah and you know what I
think everybody was kind of shocked by
that because of the way that I looked
back then and could do the things about
Hugh Hefner people thought that I was a
showboater that couldn't back it up
didn't Lord Sugar make you shave off
your moustache yeah well he didn't make
me but this is where this is where I'm
smart right so they kept talking about
the matando mustache and actually I lost
the property guitars so that when he
said look you were too young you jumped
in you saying too many stupid things
about getting higher Commission and
everything else then we went to me and
then I got through that and the next
task was the interviews so I knew they
wanted me to change my image and I knew
right if they could tell the story to
the viewers that this rough guy coming
from his background you know when he
come in it's a bit of a joke but yeah
actually backed up what he did but the
apprentice molded him into this really
slob looking businessman that I was
gonna play their storyline bore them
right so I went on that night I said to
the producer Lister I'm gonna shave my
moustache off in the morning come and
capture this because this is a piece
that you can put on so that's exactly
what I did and they're not wet looking
like this whether I was much lost it was
really sharp no no in the early stages I
look like a different character and he
generated absolute blind in story roles
he is a glowing example of the reason
that I do this apprentice process
[Music]
[Applause]